en plus
ce prince de l'ambiguïté qu'elle général
de gaulle laurence je vous ai compris
très bien mais chacun comprend ce qu'il
veut comprendre
juin 1958 nous sommes dans un contexte
de crise avec la guerre d'algérie et la
menace que le conflit s'exporte en
france pour sauver la situation
le président rené coty fait appel au
plus illustre des français le général de
gaulle le 1er juin il devient le dernier
président du conseil de la quatrième
république et par aussitôt à alger où il
prononce cette phrase entré dans
l'histoire je vous ai compris il a eu
beaucoup de deux phrases qui ont marqué
ces phrases très simple créer une
identification dans le public et les
gens adhéraient à la phrase gaullienne
il parle sans papiers
sans la foule à chaque fois il ya un
silence les phrases sont séquencé
c'est comme un acteur de théâtre sur la
scène il a besoin de sentir ce dont la
foule a besoin
et de là
il est applaudi me trompe et par tout le
monde et il est là sur le balcon du
gouvernement général d'alger face à une
foule littéralement immense mais surtout
une foule extrêmement composites il ya à
la fois les musulmans dont la majorité
en effet attend le processus de
l'autonomie puis de l'indépendance et
puis il y à nombre de pieds noirs qui
eux se retrouvent plutôt vers les
militaires et sont persuadés que
l'avenir de l'algérie c'est l'algérie
française des pieds noirs devaient
regarder les musulmans en train
d'applaudir et les musulmans devaient
regarder les piédroits en train
d'applaudir et se dire mais il ya un
malentendu
mais sur le moment il ya d'émotion
populaire et ils ne se rendent pas
compte ils ne se rendent pas compte que
le général en fin stratège donne aux
deux parties ce qu'elles veulent
entendre je vous ai compris je soutiens
l'algérie française où je vous ai
compris je soutiens l'indépendance
algérienne et l'ambiguïté le seul je
vous ai compris lui réservent au fond
liberté la liberté le gouverner la
liberté de signer une liberté qui le
mènera à choisir
l'autodétermination de l'algérie je vous
ai compris résonne alors comme une
trahison pour les partisans de l'algérie
française une petite phrase qui sonne
encore aujourd'hui comme un gros marc
câble exercice de diplomatie
[Musique]